you mentioned Guido the the benevolent
dictator for life of python what does he
think about Mojo have you talked to him
much about it uh I have talked with him
about it he found it very interesting
um we actually talked with Guido before
it launched and so he was aware of it
before it went public
um I have a ton of respect for Grado for
a bunch of different reasons you talk
about walrus operator and like Guido is
pretty amazing in terms of
steering such a huge and diverse
community and and
and like driving forward and I think
python is what it is thanks to him right
and so to me it was really important
starting to work on Mojo to get his
feedback and get his input and get his
eyes on this right now
um a lot of what Guido was is wasn't as
I think concerned about is how do we not
fragment the community yeah we don't
want a python 2 to python three thing
like that was that was really painful
for everybody involved and so we spent
quite a bit of time talking about that
and some of the tricks I learned from
Swift for example so in the migration
from Swift we managed to like not just
convert
Objective C into a slightly prettier
Objective C which we did we then
converted not entirely but almost an
entire Community to completely different
language
right and so there's a bunch of tricks
that you learn along the way that are
directly relevant to what we do and so
this is where for example the you
leverage C python
while bringing up the new thing like
that that approach is I think proven and
and comes from experience and so Guido
is very interested in like okay cool
like I think the python is really his
legacy it's his baby I have ton tons of
respect for that incidentally I see mojo
as a member of the Python family I'm not
trying to take python away from Guido
and from the python Community
um uh and so uh to me it's really
important that we're a good member of
that community and so he I think that
again you would have to ask Guido this
but I think that he was very interested
in this notion of like
Corp I think it's been up for being slow
maybe there's a path out of that
right and that you know if the future is
python right I mean look look at the the
far outside
case on this right and I'm not saying
this is Guido's perspective but you know
there's this path of saying like Okay
well suddenly python can suddenly go all
the places it's never been able to go
before
right and that means the python can go
even further and can have even more
impact on the world so in some sense
Mojo could be seen as python 4.0
I would not say that I think that would
drive a lot of people really crazy
because of the PTSD of the 3.02 I'm
willing to annoy people about emacs
versus Vim or not versus spaces that's
that one I don't know that might be a
little bit far even for me like my my
skin may not be that thick but the point
is the step to it being a superset and
allowing all of these capabilities I
think is the evolution of a language it
feels like an evolution of a language
so he he's interested by the ideas that
you're playing with but also concerned
about the fragmentation so how what are
the ideas you've learned what are you
thinking about how do we avoid
fragmenting the community where the the
pythonistas and uh
uh I don't know what to call the Mojo
people uh magicians The Magicians yeah I
like it uh can co-exist happily and and
share code and basically just have these
big code bases that are using uh C
Python and more and more movies well so
again these are lessons I learned from
Swift and and here we Face very similar
problems right and Swift you have
Objective C super Dynamic uh
they're very different syntax right but
you're talking to people who have large
scale code bases I mean Apple's got the
biggest largest scale code base of
objective c code right and so you know
none of the companies none of the iOS
developers none of the other developers
want to rewrite everything all at once
and so you want to be able to adopt
things piece at a time and so a thing
that I found that worked very well in
the Swift Community was saying okay cool
and this is when switch was very young
as you say okay you have a million line
of Code objective-c app
don't rewrite it all but when you
implement a new feature go Implement
that new class
using Swift right and so now this turns
out is a very wonderful thing for an app
developer
but it's a huge challenge for this
compiler team and the systems people
that are implementing that's right and
this comes back to what is this
trade-off between doing the hard thing
that enables scale versus doing the
theoretically pure and ideal thing right
and so Swift adopted and built a lot of
different Machinery to deeply integrate
with the objective runtime and we're
doing the same thing with python right
now what what happened in the case of
Swift is that Swift as the language got
more and more and more mature over time
right and incidentally Mojo is a much
simpler language than Swift in many ways
and so I think that Mojo will develop
way faster than Swift for a variety of
reasons but as the language gets more
mature in parallel with that you have
new people starting new projects
right and so if when the language is
mature and somebody's starting a new
project that's when they say okay cool
I'm not dealing with a million lines of
code I'll just start and use the new
thing for my whole stack now the problem
is again you come back to work
communities and we're
people that work together you build new
subsystem or a new feature a new thing
in Swift or you build a new thing in
Mojo
then you want to be end up being used on
the other side
right and so then you need to work on
integration back the other way
and so it's not just Mojo talking python
it's also python talking to Mojo right
and so what I would love to see and I
don't want to see this next month right
but what I want to see over the course
of time is I would love to see people
that are building these packages like
you know numpy or uh you know tensorflow
or what you know these packages that are
half python half C plus plus
and if you say okay cool I want to get
out of this python C plus plus world
into a unified role and so I can move to
Mojo
but I can't give up all my python
clients because they're like these
libraries get used by everybody and
they're not all going to switch ever all
you know all once and maybe never right
well so the way we should do that is we
should vend python interfaces to the
Mojo types
and that's what we did in Swift and
we're great I mean it was a huge
implementation challenge for the
compiler people right but um there's
only a dozen of those compiler people
and there are millions of users and so
it's a very expensive Capital intensive
like skill set intensive problem but
once you solve that problem it really
helps adoption it really helps the
community progressively adopt
Technologies and so I think that this
approach will work quite well with with
the Python and the Mojo world so for a
package ported to Mojo and then create a
python interface yep